anyway welcome I think with the amount
of folks here you could all just kind of
fill up the first two rows and
we should be good uh how many of you who
uh here are have come here to to to
learn
be inspired
okay well wrong talk
seriously wrong talk and and I want to
put this very disclaimer out right now
so that you don't end up saying I didn't
learn anything you're not this isn't the
place to learn fortunately for you
normally they I talk like this they put
it as a keynote so you you've got no
other choice right you're like I
paid for this thing I might as well go
uh now you've got like four other talks
you can go to if you want to learn
something here you're not going to learn
here you're just going to watch me
rant
that that's essentially it is that's
what it is this this talk is is a rant
how many of you came to my uh have you
ever seen my Silver Bullet syndrome talk
right so if you've seen that this is the
sequel to that right
it's a sequel to the Civil bullet
syndrome talk which you might be
wondering well what was that talk about
well that was a talk about me ranting at
the industry and and the industry just
doesn't stop giving right it's just over
and over again
so but with many sequels there's always
a risk right that we've seen so many
movies and and things that were great in
the first part and then totally crap in
the second part apart from tattoo tattoo
was way better in part two uh than part
one and my colleague actually put me
next to Ted at a TED talk so I've
accomplished that in my life as well
so I like to think of this as more of a
director's cut right right because first
I take the pressure away of it being a
sequel second a lot of the jokes are the
same
and uh third of all you know it's I'm
basically saying the same thing but from
a different angle the one of the things
that um
feedbacks I got with my first talk was
you know it's it's extremely uh dark and
demotivating
so the director's cut is kind of like a
new ending right no this one is still
dark and demotivating so I haven't
improved in that part but let's take a
step back and ask ourselves why are we
here I also really appreciate the fact
that someone thinks we're here to suffer
like everyone essentially the whole
world thinks that we're here to suffer
but I'm not talking about life in
general I'm talking about tech like what
are our objectives in Tech so we're here
to solve interesting problems how many
of you love solving interesting problems
raise your hands yes it was brilliant
right it's absolutely brilliant to make
boatloads of money
come on be honest
yeah I I mean I'm from Spain that that
concept doesn't exist like make
boatloads of money uh so you you don't
go into Tech in Spain to make loads of
money
uh to uh to automate everything yes yes
I love that aspect of it I mean that's
what made me fall in love with software
development and I understood that I
could actually automate stuff and and
and you know make things so much easier
and more efficient and actually end up
helping people to some sometimes we've
helped them a little bit too much
um that we don't even need those people
anymore but nonetheless it was it was a
good need right and it's to solve needs
it's to try and help people is to solve
problems that we that we have and
talking about needs you know the year
was 1990. anybody remember what happened
in the year 1990
no
no it was it was a time of good music no
um Tim barnesley uh came out with a
system to manage docs right he had a
need to manage docs he was working at
Stone and he came up with a protocol a
language a browser a web server and a
website because none of that existed
and it was basically a nice system that
he could manage docs and people could
find their way through docs it was born
out of a need now take 30 years forward
and we end up with you know our system
consists of a distributed set of
microservices that talk to each other
using graphql messages are stored in
active mq and using kafka's as Fail-Safe
option we use serverless technology to
calculate data which is stored in red as
we're looking at adopting blockchain
and this is like your grocery store that
has like 12 customers but they need the
scale right and you'll ask yourself like
why why are you doing these things what
what is the purpose and I actually want
to do this like new show which is kind
of like Gordon Ramsay going into Tech
and saying well why why are you doing
why are you combining this crap and just
as someone said to me yeah Gordon Ramsay
didn't actually make any of those
restaurants be successful I don't care
it's not about the success it's just
about the anger okay so if you want to
invest some money in me please do but uh
back in the day
right and I'm talking many many years
ago when I got into like my first kind
of official job was working as an ISP
that was like that I don't know if
anyone remembers radius software where
you had to like dial up and get
connected and we like had this frame
relay that we would allow people through
and of course we started to do that and
then we started to create websites for
people and people would email us like
descriptions of houses that they want to
sell right I live in the south of Spain
we've got sun and property to sell right
and so we would put these descriptions
up and then update the pictures and it
started to become tedious and my boss
said to me you know like stop doing this
we need to find a better way right
automate things right not have to do
this all manually
and we came up well we didn't come up we
we started to use this thing does anyone
know what that is
what is that
come on people louder
Dark Side of the Moon yes but apparently
it's also the logo for cgis I don't know
why but it is
um CGI was a common Gateway interface
and the idea was basically that you
would have your web server of course I'm
executable normally running Linux and it
would do something with it namely for
instance talking to a database Etc and
then combine that and send it back to
the server and we started to work with
these things and I at my time that was
my claim to fame right I wrote a
tutorial about isapi isapi was the
better version of it by Microsoft
because
it would allow you to not have to launch
the executable each time right that was
resource intensive so the isapi was a
dll so on the first request it would
launch load the dll into memory and then
subsequent requests wouldn't have to
have that loading and unloading and it
was way more performant and better for
memory and Netscape did the nsapi but
and it was a wonderful world it was like
really really simple right it was
brilliant you had a browser back then it
was Internet Explorer and you go to this
web to this thing computer this process
and you would interact with this
database and it would spit out some HTML
it's just how things worked right now
they call it server side rendering
okay but that's essentially what it was
and then someone said you know what this
is really cool let's add some activity
to it on the client side and Along Came
JavaScript
and JavaScript enabled us to do many
many things of course nobody really
understood JavaScript everyone went
understood jQuery and we used to ask
people like do you know JavaScript
they're like no I know jQuery and it's
fine I don't need to understand
JavaScript plus how can you understand
the language that was like you know
developed in such a short period of time
so everyone started to doing jQuery and
it was really really good and things
were kind of working well but then
people started to say no no this whole
refreshing entire page is really bad
idea it's not efficient the customers
need more they need they need instant
instant instant let's go for single page
applications and then single page
applications gave us
ton of beauty right they brought us
angle JS which allowed us to in a very
efficient way
after months create a page
and then by the time we finished
creating it the new version came out
which was completely incompatible with
the previous version so you'd spend more
time upgrading than actually creating
the application
some folks didn't like angularjs they
came out with react react was trying to
simplify things react was saying look
the web is actually a very very simple
thing let's try and simplify it and we
came up with the architecture which was
this
which was called the flux architecture
which was too hard for anyone to
understand and one person said screw
this I'm going to make reflux I couldn't
find a logo or anything so that's the
closest I got to that
but it started to go from the whole
simple concept to something more and
more complex each and every time
and this came along with its own kind of
like patterns like small talk came about
with the whole NBC right you had the
model which was your data you had the
view which was what you were seeing and
you had the controller that talked to
the bees like no I'm not doing NBC
because I'm doing desktop therefore I'm
doing MVP what is MVP well it's kind of
like the controller but it's not a
controller it's called a presenter okay
and that wasn't enough because Microsoft
said no we don't like that we like mbvm
right what is mvvm what is kind of like
presented but it's a little bit
different it's called The View model but
the view model sucked as well so we're
going to do a little with mvi what is I
it's intention what is intention it's
what the user does isn't that kind of
like what the controller does yes but
it's a subtle difference
but here is an entire blog post for you
to understand that subtle difference and
now we've got Frameworks embracing all
of these things like vue.js and we start
to see this we'll hold this whole single
page application kind of thing is
starting to give us some issues in terms
of performance right so maybe maybe just
maybe we could go back and you know do
some stuff around the server and render
the information on the server
and you get beautiful blog posts that
talk about how server-side rendering can
boost performance and user experience
like wait didn't we bring all of that
Spa to improve user experience and boost
performance no now let's go back to the
server and call it server side rendering
so we've gone full circle and the best
part about going full circle is that we
don't seem to make like we're making you
know how they say in in your in your job
like it's okay to make mistakes but it's
bad to kind of repeat the same mistakes
we're really good at that right we keep
making the same mistakes over and over
again
so you know essentially how we used to
do it so now I've got a website which is
a static website for a project I work on
which is called cator and um yeah that's
my website it's for static pages but
it's really really flexible
right it's called Gatsby and you want to
use Gatsby if you haven't don't
right
this was 12 years of progress back in 12
years ago now it's even worse okay and
if we look at what we're doing we're
basically creating data we are reading
data we are updating data and we're
deleting it
right that's what we're doing we're
doing crud
but it's shameful to say you're doing
crud because it's like you're saying
you're just a simple person
your applications are crud that's
disgusting right the crowd is very very
simple you need to think about this more
right
but we were doing this crowd and what we
did we said well you know we wrote some
code to perform all these different
actions we wrote some code that would do
a creation we wrote some code that would
do an update on a deletion etc etc and
we ended up repeating that code so we
said well you know what instead of
repeating that code let's extract that
code out and write some utility
functions which was great we then have
to repeat the code over and over again
but then we're like well we could use
this in multiple applications so instead
of writing some utility functions let's
create a library and then we could use
this Library across multiple
applications
right but then someone said no there's a
mismatch you're doing it all wrong
because you've got from one side you've
got this relational model which is a SQL
server and in University and everywhere
they've told us to think about objects
and we need to think about objects and
our applications need to be about
objects and not these disgusting
relational models that are in the
database so what did we do we wrote a
framework and we called that framework
the object relational mapper and it
didn't matter what type of database
model we would use we still wanted our
orm I mean you're using a document
database I still want my orm but there's
no relation it doesn't matter I still
want my orm all right
and then this orm starts to give us
issues
and then we're like oh what this is the
performance problems you know I want to
get all my invoices and now my invoices
is bringing all the lines and I don't
want all the lines because I only want
my invoices headers and I only want to
calculate the tops Etc so they said that
well you're designing things wrong and
thus came the big divide now the big
divide if you've not heard of it which
I'm sure you have is called command and
query responsibility segregation now
back in the old days
um that's why you'll see the reference
in this blog which is did you mean cars
does anyone know that reference right
when you used to Google cqrs Google
would say did you mean cars because
nobody knew what cqrs was back then but
it was basically taking the command and
query separation
um principle and saying well just
separate your reads from your rights
kind of like what we were doing with our
functions and our libraries in the reads
and the rights before we brought all the
object relational mapper in but of
course when this happened
and when Greg young who's one of the
folks that came up with the cqrs when he
was talking about it he was talking
about that and something called called
event sourcing
right which was basically the idea of
instead of just storing my data I would
be storing events and then play those
events which was fantastic for example
in accounting software or things that
you needed auditing Etc but what it
really understand as an industry is that
well if we're doing cqrs we have to do
event sourcing as well it didn't also
help that the event store which is the
company Greg set up was making a
database for event store event story
right event sourcing
so what we started this combine cqrs
which was actually a very very simple
concept which is just like have
different ways to read your models and
write your models and maybe separate
them in a different way with event
sourcing and that wasn't really working
out well and then there was another book
that came out which was called domain
driven design which was 500 pages and
essentially everybody the the takeaway
from domain driven design for the 90 of
us was oh I have to implement this thing
called the Repository
right the rest of it ah screw that
now I don't need any of that I'll just
focus on the repository pattern and
you're like the repository pattern isn't
really helping me no because you're
lacking aggregate routes what is an
aggregate route oh just create a class
called aggregate root and make sure
everything inherits from that and Away
you go
and uh we we came up with hexagonal
hexagonal and onion architectures and on
all these different ways to kind of like
put our applications together and you're
like wait wait a second what am I doing
here I'm just I'm just doing a crud no
crowd is too simplistic you need to
think about your ubiquitous language you
need to really Embrace that domain you
really need to do but my my app doesn't
require it doesn't matter you need to do
that and we came out with tools that for
some reason fit very well with domain
driven design which I have no
understanding of why Visual Studio fits
in with domain driven design but
apparently it was a great marketing
tactic
and they said the architecture needs
improving right because the way that
you're doing all of this is a little bit
wrong because essentially you're just
creating this massive ball of mud which
is just one service and you've got
everything crammed in there and it's
absolutely bad and that is completely
wrong
and thus came what
microservices right
which my friend Simon Brown says you
know if you can't design a proper
monolith
microservices aren't going to help you
or in less subtle terms if you've got a
bowl of this you're going to have a lot
of this right essentially that's what
you're going to end up with
and we were doing microservices which
most of them uh you know operate over
HTTP but of course you couldn't just
call your system an HTTP API that was
frowned upon right it's kind of like
saying you're just doing crowd so
everyone started to do rest of course
nobody read the rest part right they
just meant rest is pretty URLs over Json
that's essentially what it was because
rest was too hard and you didn't you
know people that really weren't even
doing rest
were saying it was too hard so that gave
us 200 okay do you know what 200 okay is
it's called graphql right that's
essentially it we started to say no now
let's take our orm and we'll just map it
over HTTP and there you go it's
beautiful
and uh so yeah so now on my website
which is a static website I have graphql
to access my icons it's beautiful
it's very very flexible though I gotta
tell you and it's adaptable
and of course all of this requires
building and when we're talking about
building like you know back in the old
days you take some source code you put
it through this thing called a compiler
it checks the language checks everything
is correct and then it puts it through
this thing that brings in the libraries
a link card and you've got your little
app it's beautiful it's soft it's
beautiful right
the problem was you had to remember all
of these command line arguments and that
was horrible
it was just disgusting like I got to
remember this over and over again now we
had these things called batch files or
command files or script files but it was
kind of bad and then of course there was
make make was really nice because it
basically allowed you to take C and C
plus plus projects and put them together
in a nice way and repeat that process
over and over again in the Java world we
got this thing called Maven anyone
familiar with maven right we've got this
thing called Maven in the.net world you
got this thing called Ms build which was
kind of the similar idea
and uh but someone said uh that's
horrible because it's XML
right XML is disgusting it's absolutely
horrible I don't want to spend my life
reading XML
and around the same time this other
thing was starting to make a come around
which was called Ruby right anyone heard
of Ruby it's dead now but it used to be
alive back then right and there was this
beautiful language called Ruby and
someone said you know what it would be
really nice if I could use that same
concept of this beautiful language to
make my build files in the same way and
of course they made this thing called
Rake and in C sharp we got cake and F
sharp they got fake
and yes JavaScript did get Jake
but JavaScript also got Grant Gulp and
of course now you got webpack which
nobody understands you've got to take a
course to understand webpack
now in the Java world
we also got Gradle right Gradle was like
well we got Ruby Ruby well groovy is a
nice language so let's try and kind of
like replicate the same idea with groovy
because it's kind of nicer and we got
this thing called Gradle and it was kind
of good right because you took all of
this ugly horrible XML which was really
really long and you substituted it for
something very very small
right and okay there was three files to
it big deal but there was still small
files right and the idea was that now
you don't need to tell the build system
how to do something you just tell it
what to do and they'll figure it out of
course to do that you need to figure out
how to tell it what to do which is like
200 Page manual
that nobody reads right so you end up on
Google asking like how do I add
dependency how do I do this how do I do
that in a very very more approachable
way to build systems and if you've ever
worked with Gradle or Maven your biggest
problem is always the cash right it just
dies right so there's there's a top hit
of like how do I refresh cash in
IntelliJ or whatever product right
fastest way to get into farming is just
delete everything and just give up that
that's essentially like this is the
process that you go through with Gradle
constantly until you just say screw it
I'm done
but we adopted Gradle at jab brains as
well right we we have this language how
many of you have heard of kotlin right
so we have this language called kotlin
and with kotlin one of the things we
want to do is try and make it
um approachable to all platforms so that
you can deploy it on any other any
platform whether it's Android iOS jvm
JavaScript native etc etc so we said
well we're going to kind of work with
Gradle because the Android Community
also works with Gradle and it's going to
be wonderful and what you can do is
basically the idea is that you write
kotlin and you share code right so you
save a lot of time instead of having to
write the same code for multiple
platforms you save a lot of time by
using uh kotlin multi-platform but of
course that time isn't time that we give
back to you that time is in time that
you can take away and say I'm going to
spend it doing my hobbies or play with
my family no that time is the time that
you spend now trying to configure Gradle
for that to work
okay so we give something but we take
something at the same time and that is
configuration and talking about
configuration XML sucks we all know it
right in fact I was talking to a
colleague of mine uh that well a friend
of mine that started a new job and he
said he was saying to me he goes
everyone around me is Young I'm like
okay it's like they don't even know what
XML is like they've never encountered
XML in their life
okay now XML how many of you like XML
it's it's good it's very explicit it it
tells you exactly what it's doing and
it's good but apparently we don't like
it why because it's two verbose because
we have to write it
so we said well let's not use XML let's
use something like Json and Json is like
okay yeah that's less verbose less you
know uh greater than lower than it's all
wonderful it's absolutely very good
but they said that no Jason isn't human
readable
because that's what I do in my life
I sit and I read configuration files as
a book
I needed to be human readable all the
time it's not like I look up something
with a search and replay no I need to
humanly sit and read that like a novel
and they said no this is no good we need
something better
which is called yaml which I don't know
why it's better but it is
because it uses white spaces I don't
know
it's it's a very long specification like
you can actually uh read through it and
figure out why yaml is more human
readable to configure stuff than Json
if you've managed to go to the end
but no someone has said no yaml stocks
so they invented Tamil and I think
Tom still uses it right
and after you build and you configure
this now you need to deploy it and
deploy you had a computer used to deploy
stuff on right you used to copy it used
to x copy it if you were on Windows used
to FTP it but then what what would
happen is that you're like oh I forgot
to file or I forgot some configuration
parameter all of this this started to
become a pain and you know the whole
works on my machine didn't work on my
machine and what did we do we fixed that
with Docker right we said well I'll just
ship my machine except we won't call it
my machine will call it a container
and the idea behind Docker is actually
genius right instead of having this
VMware I just have this um this little
container that I could put all my stuff
on make sure it's part of my build
process make sure everything happens and
it works the way it should right simple
file now of course now you're in a world
of microservices so when you've got to
go you got to go a lot right and you've
got to deploy a lot of things and you're
like well Docker comes with Docker
compose which allows me to put all of
these things together and it's really
really nice
but you know that isn't enough for you
no Docker compose and maybe some script
files and
running that is not enough no you need
the full-blown kubernetes
you need kubernetes to be able to deploy
all of this and kubernetes if you're not
familiar with it it's an open source
system for automating deployment scaling
and everything and it's meant to
simplify your life
okay
they tell you it is helpful for managing
deployments simplifying it if you run
into trouble this is a real workflow
seriously it's a real word it's not a
joke it's a real workflow of how to
debug kubernetes or someone else was
saying like this is kubernetes right
it's very very simple at the top
and then of course you have to deploy
all of these things somewhere and again
back in the old days we had an ISP we
used to put it on that on that server
and it was beautiful and then Along Came
Heroku at the same time as Ruby on Rails
which was fantastic because they really
had an ingenious idea they said okay
well you're pushing to GitHub right so
instead of pushing to your main branch
back then it was called Master instead
of pushing to your main branch what you
want to do is push to this other branch
and then what we'll do is we'll compile
it and deploy it for you of course most
of it was Ruby so they weren't really
compiling but they were deploying and it
was really really good it worked really
really well and of course some of the
big names got wind of this and they're
like oh we can do the same thing right
and then you got like Google Cloud
products right which I you can actually
scroll through to see how many Google
cloud cloud products there are and
whether you need any of these or not but
it's great it's all there right and I'm
not just picking here on I'm not I mean
I'm not picking on anyone I'm picking on
everyone even ourselves but um you know
this isn't just about Google cloud like
you get the same with Microsoft
Microsoft is also very
um pushing the idea of everything's
going to be free everything's free until
it's not free right of course once you
get it all up and running then maybe it
won't be that free I was going to create
a video of AWS but it took one and a
half hours and I said screw it
um you could just scroll down through
all of the services that they have here
there's like tons of pages and you now
of course this is good because it's all
about the cloud right so you can take uh
certification courses on learning the
cloud
but before you do that you actually
there are and I'm not joking there are
certification courses that tell you what
you need to learn
and then once you get that then you go
and learn that thing
right so we took away we said to people
you know what we're taking away you
having to manage your own hardware and
instead spend all of that time learning
all of our services which by the time
you finish learning is no longer valid
anyway because we call it for legacy
projects
right oh are you using this service on
Azure no that's for legacy use this
other new one which is much better
and then we call this Cloud native
otherwise known as vendor lock-in
right yeah I'm using serverless Cloud
native yes can you put that from AWS to
azure
well anyway right
and of course all of this you need to
Monitor and maintain and so let's talk
about devops
devops was a very very simple idea
devops was about developers and
operations having insight into what each
other is doing it was about
communication it was about awareness
what did we do we made it about tools
right like everything we do we say oh
devops no devops we need Watch Tower we
need this we need that and then we got
with this eight of devops which we're up
there as well nice
um so we've got all of these different
things right now you need a glossary of
understanding what tools you need or
even if you need them but it doesn't
matter because you do need them why
because the cloud providers are telling
you you need them
and everyone else is telling you you
need these tools right but if you have
issues with devops do not worry because
there's a scaled agile maturity
framework or short sad MF
that can help you cope
now one thing I've left all in this hour
right we've talked about design we've
talked about building configuring
everything one thing that I've left out
in all of this is security right because
security is actually complex let's talk
about it and I'm not talking about
security like authentication and
authorization that's relatively easy
right that's like you kind of like do
the best and hope it all goes well I'm
talking about this aspect of security
right I'm talking about how we've
actually built everything around us you
all remember this scenario yeah the the
the person that pulled the a little
library from npm and again I'm not
picking on npm because you have the same
in all your ecosystems that's again I
said you know like we like to learn from
our mistakes by making our mistakes
again
so we take the mistakes and one
ecosystem did and we said we're going to
repeat it exactly the same same mistakes
yep but they had that yeah we'll have it
as well
so
this was a left part which was a very
very small service and someone got
pissed off of whatever they decided to
pull it and the world broke and this was
it
that that was this that was the actual
service Community came together now you
have left dashpad.io which is a service
available 24 7 right SLA
I was looking at this many many years
ago back in 2018 I found that there was
a a package which was 18 million
downloads at the time
and had 72 dependent packages on it and
it fits in a tweet that was the actual
package
two string call R equals object array
and it was a function that's called is
array
and there's more there's is negative is
positive is zero negative is zero
positive is array is not array is false
is something like array
has identity crisis
I'm pretty sure that one's already there
as well so on that list going back to my
little Gatsby website this is where I am
right
those are all the dependencies that
Gatsby is pulling in and I have no clue
what they are
and I don't know if any of them are
doing anything malicious or not no clue
whatsoever
right I mean it just goes on and on and
on and on and on
and you've got to wonder for yourself
why oh flexibility tomorrow if I want to
scale my four page application to a
million Pages it's scalable
Shy's a friend of mine's uh drinking
game still stands you can and the beauty
of this is that you know you think of a
noun Google it if it exists drink but
this again you can look for DOT jar you
can look for DOT whatever.net is it all
exists in all the Frameworks now coming
back to security you would think well
this isn't really an issue except it is
and it's a recent issue right now we're
constantly being found in small tiny
little packages that we're building up
on and this isn't just about packages
this is about Docker containers as well
nine million Docker containers in the
registry right how many of them verified
ten thousand are you using verified
images not always right do you even know
what those verified images are who are
they verified by
so this is where we are and the worst
part is that when we build stuff we
don't even think about the versioning
you know I mean like again I'm old
school back in my days back in my days
we used to check in everything in
Version Control so we would have
reproducible builds now we just pull the
latest version and hope for the best
we don't care if the latest version is
compatible or not we just put a star and
make sure that it just builds and if
that latest version pulls in something
malicious who cares
but don't worry procurement is on the
job at Japanese we get loads of
questionnaires loads of questionnaires
from people like yeah we are uh we're uh
we're investigating supply chain attacks
right
um and we want to make sure that uh you
know the software you're providing is
accurate because we heard about this
thing called log4j yes um you're using
resharper that's written in.net uh log
for JS for Java okay so does that mean
that it uses log4j no it does not okay
thank you that's it that's what security
has been reduced to procurement and a
checklist
right and we continue to do all of this
and then we read articles about supply
chain attacks and think oh oh yeah you
know well it doesn't matter yeah but
it's going to get better it's going to
get better because we've decided that
all of this complexity isn't enough
drowning ourselves in all of this isn't
enough we need to also drown the
population in all of this right because
the cookie processing that takes 98 to
complete and hangs around for two
minutes isn't enough because all of
these options that you have to go
through to configure whether you want to
visit a website isn't enough all of that
is not enough now we need to give the
world web 3 sorry web 3 right
so yes that's where we need to go now
because now with things like you know uh
blockchain we can have a more fair and
distributed web you know you know the
web that computers are all over the
world
and different computers do different
things in a distributed way well we need
to do that
but what we have isn't right because we
need the blockchain
right and then we'll end up with yes
everyone owning content which we all
know is nonsense right and you talk
about how we don't need to succumb to
the corrupt governments and use things
like Bitcoin to to to give us
independence and then you find out about
how some of these biggest companies
maybe are not that
um non-cumbent to governments right and
you look at like this is I I still fail
to understand this whole thing like I
have tried multiple times to understand
nfts and I cannot even when I understand
what they are I'm like how why why are
we so stupid why are we so stupid as a
society that we bought into this rubbish
then I think about diamonds and I'm like
yeah people born into diamonds right the
thing that's mostly available if you
won't ever run out of diamonds people
think you do I mean how many of you know
Bernie Madoff
right if you haven't you don't know
about Bernie Madoff he's pulled off the
biggest Ponzi scheme in in in history
like he's turning in his grave he's like
I couldn't even fool people with this
nft right if you haven't watched
this movie Wizard of Lies so then you
end up with the man who paid 2.9 Million
dollars for an fmt of Jack dorsey's
first tweet loses almost 2.9 Million
Dollars
well I'm sorry you're stupid that like
sometimes you do have to say to people
you're stupid it's okay it is applicable
yeah
and if you if you enjoy watching the the
the the absolute
you know whatever it is that that NFC
and the web 3 is bringing you follow
this Twitter account it shows you just
exactly how wonderful it all is
right so in summary
in summary
what is my point no now I don't really
have a point which is the point about
what I said at the beginning like you're
not going to learn much you're not going
to be inspired nothing like that I don't
have a point and this is one of the
things that I always have around my
talks I don't have much of a point
especially like why would I how can I
make a point if I'm just angry and
ranting at things but there are some
things to think about like what are we
doing going back to the question of what
are we doing why are we doing it
so we come you know we read these blogs
we come to these conferences and we
listen to thought leaders
and we think to ourselves oh well I want
that
right I need that no you want that you
don't need it now I need it
I need it because scale
and we forget about the context
I tweeted something yesterday I said
something around the lines of uh I can't
something around the lines of uh you
know if you are
if you are implementing
if you only have a single uh interface
implementation of an interface don't use
an interface until you need it
look at that tweet there is hate from
all over the world
and like you what about this Center I
said I didn't say every freaking
scenario in the world I said this
specific scenario in this context no no
no no no you're wrong no someone else
accused me of never programming which is
true but anyway that's irrelevant
but when we come to these conferences
and we go to this talk and we're like
well just because Netflix uses
microservices and performs chaos monkey
doesn't mean we need to
but we it's so easy for us to forget
this and just because Uber switches from
MySQL to postgres doesn't mean we all
need to in fact in 2013 Uber published a
document about how they went from MySQL
to postgres
right and they said they had issues with
performance whatever and and they needed
to do this
and I remember exactly back then that
folks were trying to do the same thing
they're like well if if Uber is going to
run it has run into this issue I
definitely am going to run into this
issue you don't have the same problem as
Uber it doesn't matter I'm going to run
into this issue plus I really wanted to
play with postgres so this is my great
opportunity to do that right three years
later Uber said how they went from
postgres to mySQL
you could have saved yourself time money
and energy and waited three years and
still be more productive
how we went from microservices to
microservices and back again yes because
if you design a ball of mud
badly you're not gonna you know you're
gonna end up with multiple balls of
money that are badly
and you think like what is it that we're
trying to accomplish and all of this of
course has another side effect because
we listen to all these things we read
all these things we come to these
conferences I mean lately I read
Conference titles and I don't even
understand the Conference titles anymore
it's like how to blah blah blah with
blue and blue blue
okay
and all of this you know leads us to
analysis paralysis right it's like okay
so should I be using active mq or
rapidmq should I be using documentdb or
relational model should I be using
microservices or monolith should I what
patterns should I be using what
architecture do I need and we send out
more time trying to investigate all of
these things and think about all of
these things which oftentimes aren't
even necessary but you know when you go
to when you go to a candy store you're
like oh I got all of these candies which
ones do you dig I don't need any of them
but look at all these like yesterday I
was talking to Kevin he's like oh you
know I I uh we're talking about guitars
and he's like yes because um uh I I I I
don't need uh I don't need a guitar I'm
like of course you don't need you know
it's like I don't necessarily need this
of course you don't like there are some
things in life that you don't
necessarily need
and then we end up focusing on the what
as opposed to the why
it's like what should I be doing
so then you start to wonder to yourself
why are we doing this thing is it a CV
driven development right because that's
essentially what's ending up right look
at your CVS look at my CVS everyone's
CVS when you do a CV what do you say I
managed to solve XYZ problems or help
XYZ amount of people no you say I know
angularjs react.js graphql blah blah
blah blah blah blah and we write our
series like this and we hire people like
this because we think that what people
have a limited capacity of learning
and we don't learn on the job
and we're going to be classified by the
number of technologies that we know oh
and yet this is where we are
and we're like no but it's nice it's
knowledgeable it's it's like driven by
in a knowledge driven development and
we're very very fortunate you imagine if
if civil engineers that are making
Bridges like I've never done this kind
of bridge but I'm going to try it just
in case you know it may fail
and and you know what I'll do five just
in case Tomorrow there's more cars
coming through uh it will be scalable
right
he was like we're really weird as an
industry oh well
it didn't work I learned I learned and
then we complained that our like you
know our employers need to to pay for
our education they're doing it every
bloody day every time we open a a new
product and thing that we haven't used
we're learning on the job
but you don't ask yourself do you really
need that or more importantly does my
customer really need that
we don't we hardly focus on that aspect
and we're just driven by this Passion by
this love for trying to solve problems
and and and engage with difficult things
and it's on our nature I mean that's
that's what it is right as as
individuals as developers we're like
that and the industry is made up by
developers and it's encouraging us it's
giving us 600 services that we may never
need but they look really cool to play
with so let's maybe bring some of those
into our application
but you don't need it it doesn't matter
it's still very very cool
and I'm not saying that there aren't
complex systems in in the world surely
there are right
but you know this idea of we're building
with flexibility in mind sometimes we
need to take this step back and think
are we actually
making a system way more complex
by doing this when we talk about we're
building for change when we talk about
we're building clean architectures
all of this comes at a cost the majority
of clean architectures and clean is
relative right because your clean is my
dirty and my dirt is you're filthy right
but all of this comes at a cost
and all of this flexibility and
abstractions and all of these things
that we build in often we don't end up
using the back back to the orm days I
was one that would build an abstraction
over an orm how stupid is that but I
would do it why just in case one day I
would have to swap my orm out did I ever
swap my Aurora never
but I would build these abstractions and
we do this on many many things
I mean like no we're striving to build
clean code yes but at what cost
right how many times do we actually need
that
but it's like we have this urge for
complexity and we want to solve complex
problems with more complexity and it's
like you know it's something like
well it's a complex problem and if you
want to understand this you have to
really understand the complexity why
do we take pride in complexity
why are we not trying to make things
simple is it job security of course not
so we need to try and move back to
Simplicity it's okay it is absolutely
okay to make things easier it is okay to
raise the level of abstraction but if
it's harder for me today to deploy an
application using kubernetes than
learning 68 800 for the Motorola that's
not going in the right direction is it
we've created an abstraction but we made
it very hard to understand but of course
it's not an easy task
because it's that balance of okay how
can I make the subtractions how can I
make it simple how can I solve problems
it's not easy
but it seems that we very often take the
root of well it's just complex so folks
need to understand this complexity
so we need to strive to make things
simpler
because all of this is coming at a cost
and it's coming to a cost for ourselves
and consequently our employers or if
you're self-employed to yourself
Etc right and we strive so much about
talking about user experience and making
the lives of our users simpler and
making it easier for our users to not
have to learn interfaces or read
documentation to understand how things
are
and yet so we strive for that simplicity
but we don't seem to do that Simplicity
for ourselves
right for us it's like oh well this
framework solves all the problem except
this 10 so I'm going to make it a little
bit more complex and everyone can learn
my new framework which is solving all of
the problems that they don't have but
anyway they're going to learn that so we
really really really need to try and
strive for Simplicity
it's okay to solve complex problems but
try and do it in a simple way and I'll
finish with this um very very famous
quote which I'm sure you've all heard
before right he says you don't want
Simplicity because you can't handle
Simplicity you need the complexity you
want the complexity we use acronyms like
yagni kiss and dry we use these as the
backbone of a life spent designing with
Simplicity in mind you use it as a
punchline
I'm sure you've watched that movie
okay thank you
[Applause]
and that means that you're free to go to
your continuous eating
thing earlier